Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is Joe De Sena.
Joe is the founder of Spartan,
the whole Spartan Race Series.
This is an incredible conversation.
I think it's designed to really inspire how you think about
the new year and get you off on the right trajectory
as we think about 2021.
So without further ado, hit that subscribe button
and please enjoy my conversation with Joe De Sena.
Right on man, so good to see you.
We've been trying to make this happen for so long.
It's taken forever, man.
I don't know how many, gotta be three or four years.
Couple of years, I think the last time I saw you,
I did your show when you guys
were hosting an event at Dodgers Stadium.
Yeah, I think like a last minute,
hey Rich, can you come over to the stadium?
And we caught you and we did some filming
and we knocked out a podcast.
Right, we did a podcast
and then I did a little shooting
with you for the documentary with Cal Fussman.
What happened to that documentary?
It's done and off the editing room floor,
however you'd say it, and getting ready to be pushed out.
What's it called?
"What The Fuck is Your Exit Strategy?"
And the idea is, and it probably,
I know it pisses you off.
What are people thinking when they don't eat healthy,
when they don't act healthy?
And so like what,
like we talk about exit strategy in business.
What's your exit strategy from the planet?
Do you plan on living in a hospital for the last 20 years?
And that title came about because Cal,
a mutual friend of ours,
Cal Fussman famous writer invited me
to breakfast with Larry King one day.
And so I'm sitting there-
At Nate 'n Al's?
Yeah, so I'm having a salad and Larry is pouring.
I mean, pouring sugar all over this bowl of cereal.
"Ah kid, what are you doing with the salad?"
And he goes, "I eat like this.
I got a colonic every day," and I just thought,
"Fuck, what's the exit strategy?"
(laughing)
And it came from there, so is Cal, like the protagonist,
he's who were like taking this adventure with?
Yeah, we took the adventure with him
and he was impossible to deal with.
And unbeknownst to me, you know, 20 years earlier,
he did it maybe 30 years earlier,
he did it with Jack LaLanne,
and I think Cal was really good
for an article or for film,
but then like most people falls off the wagon
when there's no reason to be taking care of yourself.
I just remember him being sort of obstinate
in the interview, like pushing back
and it's like, come on, man,
what do you, what do you, you know, get on board here.
Listen, I fought my in-laws when I met my wife,
my mother, by the way, my mother in the 70s
was into yoga, meditate,
all the stuff that we're into.
And she fought the whole world.
And so there were no Whole Foods or yoga journals back then.
So I watched the pushback and, and it's, I mean,
maybe not in California,
but the pushback is massive everywhere to this idea
of just take care of yourself.
I mean, look at COVID in the US versus everywhere else.
Mm. Yeah. I wanted to ask you.
I mean, it's gotta be brutal right now for you with Spartan.
How are you keeping this thing from capsizing?
You know, when it first happened,
I became friends two years ago,
skiing with the owner of Saks fifth Avenue,
he owns Hudson Bay company,
which is the equivalent of Saks in Canada,
Saks Fifth Avenue.
Incredibly successful guy.
And when it was all going down, I was with Gerard Butler.
Check this out, I was with Gerard Butler,
I was in Sparta, Greece for the 2,500-year anniversary
of Thermopylae, the movie was based
on the battle of Thermopylae.
And Trump closes the border,
and at that moment it became very real.
Because up until then, we had closed a few races in China,
had closed a few races in Japan,
but it was like no big deal,
this thing will be over in a jiffy.
And I'm in Sparta and the country gets shut down
and I call my friend from Saks and I'm like, what the fuck?
And he says, he goes, "You gotta preserve cash.
You gotta preserve cash,
you gotta protect the employees that you can,
and you got to stay in touch with your customers."
And thank God I had that phone call on March 13th, 14th,
because I would have just like,
I mean we had 501 people working for us.
I got 325 events shut down overnight around the world,
and you can't keep paying people and bills
and all these things and lawyers and,
you know better than anybody,
the lawyers and not have revenue coming in.
So, you know, I'm ashamed to say,
I thought, I didn't listen to the advice of him,
I didn't listen to the advice of my friends
that run hedge funds.
I thought come July 1, we're back. The world is back.
Well, we've never seen anything like this
in our lifetimes.
There was no reason to think that we wouldn't be able
to get over the hump and get back to some level of normal.
And I'm an optimist.
I mean our whole business is based on optimism, right?
And I just thought, yeah, well, here we are.
So did you have to lay off a bunch of people?
350 people furloughed.
And I think we just did a few more.
Silver lining in all of this is we became
a lot more efficient as an organization.
There were a lot of deficits in our company
that we never tended to; technology, CRM, e-com,
go down the list,
things that we just didn't have time for,
putting on 325 events.
And so we're becoming much better in those areas,
but it's really a race against the clock.
It's, you know, if we're back on next year
and we're allowed to put on events, it's gonna be great.
But, I just don't know.
I mean, China, two weeks ago had 10,000 kids
at a Chinese event in China.
China's back in business.
They got vaccines that cost $30 USD.
I mean I could go up to the corner store
and get a shot in our arm.
But outside of that...
Yeah, so you can ramp up in China.
I could ramp up in China, but the US
was 50% of our business.
Europe was 25% of our business, right?
So China does not offset, but it gives us hope
that if China's back and they were three or four months
before us in shutting down,
maybe three or four months from now we'll be back.
Yeah. We'll see.
We'll see.
Who knows.
Who fucking knows.
It's craziness.
I know, it's so crazy.
Well, what I've noticed in you
just from a distance is this kind of pivot
into really a media company, like a content platform,
like suddenly you're vlogging all the time
and suddenly there's videos from you
like every single day.
I know, I've gone a little nuts. I apologize for that.
We locked down on the farm in Vermont.
That's where this whole thing was started.
My wife and I had our four children,
I don't know how to say that politically correctly.
She birthed four kids on the farm.
I think you're allowed to say that.
Yeah, in Vermont, along we had cows
and chickens and goats.
And that's where Spartan was started.
As soon as I got back from the Thermopylae thing
I just described in Sparta, Greece, landed on the farm,
holed up with an Olympic wrestler.
That's another whole story.
A video team, a bunch of people on the Spartan team,
trainers and so forth, 12, 13 of us.
And we just started filming every day
because there was nothing else to do.
Like preserve your cash, protect your employees
and stay in touch with your customers.
So just film, film, film, film, film,
because I like to work and we couldn't put on events.
And so that's what we did.
Yeah, and you keep the brand strong
and you keep people excited about what Spartan is,
and they hear it from you directly.
Yeah. So just lots of filming.
But as you know, it drains your energy levels because you,
like right before we just started this podcast,
anybody listening or watching,
Rich and I were talking regularly.
As soon as the filming started, you perked up,
your chest came out.
Did I?
Yeah, and you were like on.
I'm trying to be normal, man.
I want this to be as relaxed as possible-
No, but we both did it.
You don't even notice you're doing it, right?
So it just sucks energy out of you.
Well, I just noticed, like, this is,
I think this is the fifth podcast I've done
in the last seven days.
We're on a bit of a tear and it's draining, man.
Like I, you know, I don't know like how Rogan does,
you know, four or five of these things a week.
Maybe it's cause he doesn't prepare.
But like, I prepare, like I put a lot of energy into it.
I want it to be this amazing experience.
And when it's done, it's kind of like an athletic event.
Then I go home and I crash.
And now like, yeah, it's like,
it is its own kind of endurance thing.
And it does take, even though it's not physical,
there's an emotional, like energy toll that it takes.
It'd be easier, I think you'd agree with this.
It would be easier to go for a run.
Oh, for sure.
Right?
Yeah.
And your mind is working,
but your body, you're breathing, you're sweating.
Also I can control that, you know.
With this, it's sort of like, there's an aspect
of trying to, you know, have guard rails up
and direct it in a certain way.
But at the same time you have to like, let go
and allow it to be what it wants to be.
So there's a vulnerability with that
that's different from going out and pushing yourself
where it's just you and you.
No doubt.
And so, I just went through, you know,
let's call it 120 days straight of filming
on the farm every day.
And something cool happened this week,
and you might not know about is once we realized,
hey, this is going to go on longer than we thought,
it's gonna be much more painful than we thought,
we got to lay off more people, I said, you know,
we need an event, we need one event.
Something to show our community, seven million people
that like, we're still here and shit's still happening.
So this past weekend we brought 12 women, 12 men
from CrossFit, from triathlon, from the NFL, Spartan.
And we brought them all together to find out
who's the fittest of them all.
And my team came up with a whole thing.
I can't even tell you all the names of the athletes
that were there, because my team organized,
I just wanted to have a Spartan event.
And they came up with this whole thing.
They actually wouldn't allow me back on my own farm
because I needed another COVID test.
So here I was, outside my own farm
while this was going down.
But, we had a Highland games type event.
We had an ultra run, we had a triathlon swim,
we had a mountain bike, we had a DECA event,
which is our almost gym product if you would.
A combination of the Airdyne bike
and the rowing machine and all that.
We had a race to the top of the mountain
and we had a Spartan race.
And I don't want to give anything away.
But you would think, you would think that the specialists
in each one of those areas would win their area
and I'll just leave you with this, they didn't.
Yeah, that's interesting. That's fascinating.
I would suspect that the person that comes out on top
has a lot more to do with their mental fortitude
than their physical prowess or their athletic gifts.
It's so funny you say that, because I was thinking,
and you'd correct me if I don't have this right.
But I thought, all right, let's measure,
let's set some,
what are the items we're going to measure?
Strength, speed, endurance, athleticism.
And then I said, wait,
but you gotta also measure resiliency and grit, right?
Because some of this is gonna require
resiliency and grit.
And when you look at, without me giving it away
who the winners were,
they were the ones with the resilience and grit.
Yeah, yeah, 100%.
'Cause I don't know how long this thing-
Five days.
Yeah, so that's gonna separate the wheat
from the chaff, right?
That's like a reality show.
It was so frigging unbelievable.
It's just so unbelievable,
you can't even imagine what went down.
It's a show.
Yeah, that's cool.
Well, I want to take it back.
Your backstory is so epic. I mean, it's cinematic.
It's like its own movie. It's just a crazy fucking story.
It's a crazy story.
And you're quietly like such a beast
in terms of like the endurance stuff that you've done.
Like it's insane. I feel like that gets overlooked.
But let's go back to the beginning, back to Queens.
So if anybody's, have seen the movie, "Goodfellas"
out there, raise your hand.
Most people have seen it, right?
Ground zero for that movie was the block I grew up on.
I'm trying to remember the exact address, but 84th Street,
140 Ninth Avenue in Lindenwood, Queens
or Howard Beach, Queens, Jamaica.
And for whatever reason,
a bunch of wise guys located on this particular block
and their game, their profession
was stealing from Kennedy Airport.
And that's what's portrayed-
That's exactly what's in the movie.
And so there wasn't a morning that went by
where I didn't wake up with my sister,
and we'd go down into the garage.
And there was a new big box on a pallet of things there.
Like it could be leather ski gloves, 500 pairs.
It could be Adidas Superstar sneakers.
Just heisting the cargo trucks that are coming in and out.
Yeah, and so it was very common to go shopping,
we were young, my sister and I at this point and my friends,
but you'd go shopping in someone's house.
It wasn't like, you don't have to go to the store.
You went to someone's house,
and there was all kinds of, but you don't know as a kid
what this means.
Anyway, we grew up in this crazy neighborhood.
My parents are getting along. Everything's fine-
Your dad part of that or just the neighbors?
So the way I'll answer it is,
my dad had a trucking business in the airport,
eventually a fairly large warehouse
and air freight business, and...
It was hard to be in that business unless-
You couldn't be in that business
unless you have some relationship to the mob.
Some relationship with it.
But I will say my dad, no BS,
my dad was amazing in that his thing was,
if you go in that direction,
you waste so much energy and so much time,
and you can't spend the money because it's not legal.
Like you'd be better off putting all that time and energy
into a legitimate way, a legitimate life.
But I'll say that, like if you grew up there
and you come from that place and you're in that bit,
it's pretty hard to not be in it.
It was nobody not in it in that neighborhood.
Right.
I can't go deeper than that, but-
I got it.
You got it?
Yeah.
And there's very few people left.
So anyway, my parents are getting along.
My dad starts making some real money
and we move 15 blocks South
of where we were, which is a better area.
And our neighbor is the head
of the Banana organized crime family, 15 blocks up
and around the corner is the big boss of the Gambinos.
And there's four of the five family heads
are living just around us in this area,
15 blocks south of where I first grew up.
And my mom goes into a...
Her mom dies of cancer.
My mom goes into a health food store to just explore
like is there another way to live rather than,
you know, ganolis and raviolis and pizza,
and she just didn't feel healthy,
and she watched her mom just die.
She walks into a health food store,
which is probably the only health food store
on the entire East Coast at this point.
And there's a yogi, like an 85-year-old yogi
that just landed at Kennedy Airport,
probably from India in the store.
And she starts talking to him and somehow he convinces her
that she's got it all wrong, and she's got to become vegan,
and she's got to start meditating
and she's got to take up yoga,
and how to breathe and cold showers,
all the stuff we talk about now.
And she comes home and she throws out
the sausage and peppers,
and like literally transforms the house,
which ultimately leads to divorce.
Your dad's losing his shit with this.
Everybody, we were as kids,
because if you're listening to this, this sounds somewhat,
it was not-
no, not at all at that time.
She might as well have just landed from Mars, right?
That's how crazy the stuff was that she was preaching.
And so they get divorced and she moves us back
north to that 15 blocks, right?
So my sister and I are down there for about a year.
My dad's at the other house.
And then she's just not fitting in.
Nobody's getting this thing that she's preaching.
And she moves to Ithaca, New York,
because that was like where the hippies were
and they were educated-
She's going Moosewood.
She's going Moosewood, exactly.
That was a big part of our life.
And I'm kicking and screaming,
my sister's kicking and screaming.
We don't want to leave our friends in the neighborhood,
any kid would feel this way.
And I'm attracted as a young boy,
I'm attracted just like all the other boys in town are
to the guys with Cadillacs, the guys with suits on,
the guys with rolls of $100 bills in their pockets.
Like we kind of know what they're doing,
who doesn't wanna be that?
Right, and what is the difference
between the wise guys you see in the movies,
whether it's "Goodfellas" or "The Sopranos"
versus like your real life experience with these guys?
There's really no difference.
I mean from my perspective of that age,
no one's ever asked me that,
they were a lot more quiet in real life.
But a film has to give you the behind the scenes.
And so, you know what I mean?
They were a lot more quiet.
They didn't have to say much, they earned respect.
You kinda, you just didn't mess around, right?
Like you would imagine.
But very much the same...
In the "The Godfather" and "Goodfellas" and "A Bronx Tale",
like they did a really good job.
Like captured it.
They really captured the mannerisms.
Sopranos, not as much.
I didn't feel it in "The Sopranos"
but in those other movies.
And the thing that you get is this idea,
that even though they're outlaws, they still have,
you know, these rules and this code that they live by.
And, you know, there's certain aspects of that ethic
that are laudable, right?
It's not all bad, right?
And so, as a young kid, who's impressionable,
you see the bling, but you also see
there's a value system there that you can
kind of hang your hat on.
Definitely hang your hat on it.
Things got taken care,
like everybody runs into a problem in life.
Everybody runs into a problem.
And so here, if you're sick-
The community's taking care of each other.
Like I remember running to the boss next door,
as I got older and let me go backwards.
Mom moves to Ithaca.
My dad falls on hard times, the '87 market crash hits.
All the things he's working on
are starting to fall apart a bit.
And the neighbor sees this and he says, you know,
and I'm probably 12 years old.
And he says, come over and clean my pool Saturday.
So that's a big deal, you know,
getting tapped on the shoulder,
and the boss wants me to come over and clean the pool.
So I go over and clean the pool,
and he sits me down and he gives me three lessons that day.
And he says, look, if you're going to be here 8:00 am,
you show up 7:45, on time is late.
Good advice.
You'd think I'm at Stanford, right?
You're getting an MBA.
Yeah, if you're gonna clean the pool,
I want you to clean the lawn furniture, the shed,
the windows, whatever it takes, make yourself invaluable.
All right, that seems fair.
And three, never ask for money.
You'll get paid if you do a good job,
don't have your hand out.
And unbeknownst to me at that moment in time,
he's grooming, he's seeing,
here's a hard working young kid, right?
And then he gives me another customer, you know,
two houses over who happens to be connected to him.
And then I got another boss's house.
And before you know it, I've got 700 customers.
I pay for my own college.
How old are you at this point?
Well, I started at 12.
By the time I graduated college, I'm 20, 700 customers.
It's a multimillion dollar business at that point,
and it's all these guys.
And so I could walk in anybody's house.
And so I'm feeling,
this is great.
Right?
Like everybody trusts me.
And you're taken care of.
I'm taken care of.
If you get in trouble...
So that was my point.
So my dad is telling me, and he's right.
Stay away from that life.
But you find yourself, even if you,
push back on that life, make fun of that life,
say that's ridiculous, those guys are terrible,
you find yourself in a situation where like,
somebody owes you money or you did, whatever it may be.
And then all of a sudden it comes okay
to ring their bell, right?
And say, "Hey, I need a favor."
Right.
And then you're in it.
Once they do that favor for you though, that's-
And technically because he got me in the business, like,
I mean I couldn't say no to anything.
Right.
Right?
Did you call upon those guys to do some favors for you?
And then did you find it difficult
to then extricate yourself from the whole thing?
Well, so yes, I asked for favors often
because people owed me money.
And I remember saying to Joe once,
a guy owed me $60,000.
And he said, bring this bottle of champagne
over to his house and just let him know it came from me.
And so I go over to the house, I don't ask for the money.
I just say, "Hey, Joe asked me to drop this off for you."
And he literally goes over to the wall,
takes a painting down, opens the safe, like in a movie,
grabbed 60,000 in cash and hands it to me.
I didn't even...
(Rich laughing)
And there were a few incidences like that.
Now, to the second part of the question,
did you find yourself beholden?
I guess I got lucky in the sense that Giuliani came to be,
and then one by one, all these guys,
(talking over each other)
they all started to go to jail.
And so, I didn't have a long tail in, like it was good.
Right, right, right.
I didn't know it at the time.
So where does Cornell come into the whole thing?
Like kind of in the middle of the pool business, right?
Yeah, so I'm running this business.
I'm feeling great, it's growing.
I buy a backhoe and a Bobcat and I got a building.
And like, like it's a real business, right?
My mom's living in Ithaca.
So I have to spend a lot of time in Ithaca,
that's where I live.
Going back and forth, running the business,
by my dad's house, going back to mom.
And I'm leaving high school in Ithaca,
going back to run my business,
no intention of going to college.
I didn't have like most families where they bring you
on a college tour.
Even though I lived in Ithaca where Cornell was,
no one told me anything about school,
and my grades weren't that good.
And my friend says to me, "Hey, why don't we go to Cornell?"
I'm two months from graduating high school,
and I say, "Well, how would we go to Cornell?"
And he said, "My dad's a professor. He'll get us in."
And that made perfect sense to me because I grew up
in the neighborhood where you'd have a guy
and he would get you into a restaurant or whatever.
So this is like, yeah, we got us in college.
So we both get dressed up, we do our interviews,
we do everything we're supposed to do.
It's gonna be a shoe in.
and neither of us get accepted.
And now I was intrigued like, oh,
we have a guy, we can't get in,
and now I'm intrigued in this thing.
Tell me I can't, now I gotta do it.
Where does that come from?
'Cause that's just born and bred into you.
Probably a neighborhood thing.
Like when we, let's go back to your conversation
about resiliency and grit and those athletes.
In this neighborhood, these guys went to jail,
they got killed, and that was just part of the job, right?
And then if you were running a somewhat legal business,
you owned the local pizza place,
or a trucking company or whatever, you hustled.
You were up at 5:00 AM, the diesel trucks were running,
the pizza place was second generation, third generation.
They were making, you know what I mean?
Like everybody just hustled.
So probably comes from that.
It probably comes from just seeing this, like, you know,
fuck that, I'm gonna get this done.
Kinda like, there's no no, right?
Right, so you get the no.
We get the no, and now I wanna go,
and I'm debating going back to run my business.
And my friend says, "Listen, my dad just said,
we can go extramural, we could take three classes each.
When everybody else gets matriculated into Cornell,
we can take three classes each.
They'll do five, we're not official,
but if we do well, they have to let us in."
Logical, so I said, okay, you know what we'll do then?
I said, when I go back to Queens
to run my businesses this summer, I'll go to St. John's.
It's in my route anyway and all the pools I clean
and the work I'll do.
I'll stop in St. John's, I'll take a couple of classes.
I'll learn how to study.
And then when I'm going to Cornell, if we get in,
I'll have gotten my five classes done,
I won't be behind the other kids.
My friend says to me, "That's ridiculous.
If we're gonna hustle in September at Cornell,
why don't we go to Vegas all summer and party?"
Right.
Right?
And that was a divergence right there,
and that was a real big lesson for me
on like delaying gratification.
So he heads to Vegas, I head to St. John's.
I run my business. We both meet up in September.
We do our three classes.
We do very, very well.
I get two A's and a B.
And for me at an Ivy league school, two A's,
I never got two A's ever.
And reapply.
Definitely getting in now.
They don't accept us.
Right.
And now I'm even more invested.
I did my classes at St. John's.
I just studied my ass off, and they didn't accept me.
And the woman, the admissions woman says to me,
"Listen, we'd have everybody and their brother,
you know, trying to get in here if this was allowed.
You're gonna have to go to another school,
and then after three years at like Ithaca College
or somewhere else, then, then apply."
And I was like, "Maybe you didn't hear me.
I'm gonna go here."
(both laugh)
So I'm gonna do it again.
Then she's gotta let me in.
And so he diverts, my friend taps out-
Does he go back to Vegas?
He goes back to Vegas, he goes to UNLV.
And I go back, do another semester, do well, reapply.
They don't accept me. Do another semester. I do well.
Don't accept me.
My fourth semester, I'm broken.
I finally, I hit my limit.
This is your own death race.
Yeah, it's my own death race.
And I'm just feeling like my business is doing well.
I got all these, like, I don't need this.
I don't need the headache.
And I tell my mom, you know, I'm gonna pack it in.
And she was probably bragging for four semesters,
her son was going to Cornell,
even though I technically was not a Cornell student.
And she says, go meet my yoga,
she teaches yoga, my mom at this point in the living room.
And she says, go meet my yoga student,
Professor Anita Rasin.
She might be able to help you, I don't know.
And my mom was the last person I would have asked,
like for a connection.
'Cause she was crunchy and Bohemian
and my dad would have had the contact.
So anyway, out of respect to my mom,
I go meet professor Anita Rasin,
she sits me down, looks at my grades,
asked me a bunch of questions.
She says, you know, I run a department
within one of the schools at Cornell, textiles.
We study textiles.
And there's 92 women in the department, there's no men.
Do you like textiles?
I was like, "I love textiles."
I didn't even know what a textile was.
Like I'm in.
And so she finally accepts me and I ended up
spending the rest of my time at Cornell studying textiles,
which if I had to do it again, I would do,
because I could watch any movie from any era
and tell you based on hemlines, what time-
That's amazing.
Yeah, when that happened.
What years were you at Cornell then?
I entered in '86, graduated in '90.
Aha, so you left right before I got there
'cause I went to law school at Cornell.
Okay, law school is beautiful.
I was there '92 to '94,
so you were out there.
But then you got in legitimately.
You didn't need to pull strings.
No, well, legitimately sort of,
I was the last person admitted to the law school class
off the wait list.
So I showed up, like,
I didn't think I was going to law school.
I got in at the last minute, I was living in New York city
and packed a bag and tried to figure out where Ithaca was
and showed up.
And everybody had been studying all summer.
And I was like, what am I even doing here?
'Cause I'd already decided I wasn't gonna go,
and it was like a very spontaneous decision.
And you liked it when you arrived?
I mean, I liked being,
I was getting out of control in New York.
So I liked being in a structured environment
and I like school and the law school,
it's kind of like "The Shining" there though,
because it's so fucking cold.
And you're all in this one building
and a lot of the 1Ls live in a dorm
that's attached to the law school.
So they never go outside.
So it gets a little weird and incestuous,
but I basically just spent most of my time at Rulloff's.
I bar backed at Rulloff's.
Oh, you did?
I mean, I was there like four nights a week.
I was gone by the time you got there.
But I think I made $16 a week.
That's tough, when you're making
like mid-six figures or whatever you were making
in the pool business.
Exactly, but it was good for me to,
it was a way from me to mingle and meet other people
while I, I like to work.
Obviously you're hearing that in my story.
And rather than wasting time just drinking,
which is the way I looked at it.
I was around it while I was working, getting paid.
I could have used you in my orbit back then, man.
I needed a little discipline at the time.
Cool, so then you get out of Cornell,
but then it's back to the pool business?
So first of all, anybody listening
that doesn't know Cornell and correct me
if I'm wrong, Rich.
But the law school to me feels most like Cambridge
or Harry Potter, at least from the outside,
it has that look, right?
So I'm about to graduate on time,
which was unbelievable because I was so far
behind from those four semesters.
And I take professor Ben Daniel's class
at the Graduate Management School, MBA program.
Right, you didn't combine it, like-
I didn't do the combined.
They didn't accept me for the combined.
It was just, I clearly was not smart enough
for this whole thing, but I was allowed
to take a class there.
A lot of people took the entrepreneurship class
at that school.
And as part of it, we all came up with a business plan
and we presented that business plan to a panel of judges.
And I won, I won the $5,000 award
that came from the owners of Riunite Wines.
They were awarding every semester,
$5,000 to the best idea, best presentation.
And the judge, one of the judges was an Italian guy,
and being from the neighborhood I'm from,
I clicked with him and I bought him a bottle of Sambuca.
I brought ir over his house and we got to know each other.
I didn't buy the winning slot, by the way.
I just got to know him.
I got to know him.
Okay.
And he said, "What are you doing when you graduate?"
And I said-
Well, first of all, what was the idea
that allowed you to win?
So do you remember at Cornell, and many colleges,
they had champion branded sweatshirts with the silk letters
sewn on the front, and they were $50 or $40.
And I just thought the way those sweatshirts were made,
people would buy the champion sweatshirts,
the stores at Cornell, or any, would buy the sweatshirts,
and then they'd have a couple of seamstresses,
'cause I was studying textiles,
would sew those letters on.
And I just thought I could make them in Asia.
I could make them for each school,
I would change the wristbands,
I'd add a little bit of Lycra so they didn't blow out
'cause everybody would roll up their sleeves.
You'd wear those things a couple times,
and they were done.
They would blow out.
And so I had this idea for a better cut sweatshirt
that was cut in stone in Asia, labeled in Asia.
And they liked the idea. So they gave me $5,000 to do it.
It's amazing you didn't go into becoming
some huge garmento.
I should have.
Yeah, I should have in retrospect.
So he says to me, "What are you doing when you graduate?"
I say, "I'm going back to the neighborhood.
I got this business.
He says, "You're an idiot."
I said, "What do you mean?"
He said, "You have a work ethic.
I can see it, you can talk, you should go to Wall Street."
And I didn't really know much about Wall Street.
I just knew the '87 crash.
And I just decided that, you know,
I want to run my business.
Gotti was becoming a really big name back then,
and I was plugged into that whole thing.
And he stayed in touch with me.
So I went back to the neighborhood, I run my business,
kept building it up and he stayed in touch with me.
He called me, this guy called me every month, on the month.
Have you sold your business yet?
Have you gone to Wall Street?
No, Al, stop calling me.
Every month for like 35 months.
Wow.
Okay? And finally he convinces me.
He calls me one day and he says,
"Hey, I'm gonna give you a stock tip.
If you're not gonna listen to me,
I'm gonna give you a stock tip."
And I had never bought a stock before,
I was busy running my business.
And he says, I want you to buy the stock Syntex.
So it's probably like 1993, '94.
I want you to buy the stock Syntex.
Again, I don't have an account,
I don't know anything about it.
That day, I'm going to pick up money from a pharmacist.
One of my customers is a pharmacist.
He owns a pharmacy and he must know
about this pharmaceutical Syntex.
I ring his bell, I'm going to pick up my check.
And I said," Hey, my buddy just told me
to buy this stock, Syntex."
He goes, "I can't believe you're bringing that up."
I said, "What do you mean?"
He says, "I was just taking a shower.
I was thinking I'm gonna buy some today."
And he brings me in the house and he hands me my check.
He owes me a lot of money.
And we had done more than-
Yeah, it was like 140 grand or something like that, right?
Because then we were not just doing swimming pools.
We were rebuilding houses, doing patio work, et cetera.
And he sits me down, he calls up his broker and he says,
"Hey, you should buy 10,000 shares of this thing."
$14 share, 140 grand.
And, you know, he goes, you're single.
If you don't, you're making a lot of money right now.
If you lose it, it's no big deal.
When you're married and you've got children...
So anyway, he talks me into it, I buy 10,000 shares.
Next day, the company gets taken over.
I made a hundred thousand dollars and I was like,
I'm going to Wall Street.
This is a hell of a lot better than cleaning swimming pools
and having to chase my money and bring bottles of champagne
to get the safe to open.
So, anyway, that was it.
I sold my business to my employees. They still run it today.
They are multimillionaires. They're great guys.
And went to Wall Street.
Wow, and had to take a serious pay cut initially, right?
Big pay cut, I went down to a 35 grand a year.
And then thought I was a genius and started trading stocks
and options, and lost most of the money I had accumulated
up until then.
But then dug myself out and figured it out
and ended up building a business and started my own firm
where we executed orders, believe it or not,
for the JP Morgans, the Morgan Stanleys,
Goldman Sachs, Bank of Americas, they were our customers.
Everybody says, why would the big banks give business
to a pool guy?
And I just learned in the neighborhood
how to service customers, how to do a good job,
a better job than whoever they were using.
People skills.
I have good people skills. We hustled.
If we had to take a loss on a trade,
kind of like clean the windows and clean the shed,
even though you're only getting paid to clean the pool,
don't ask for money.
If we had to lose money, we lost money.
And then there was one secret weapon I had,
which nobody had, my neighbor who ended up going to jail,
had a table at a restaurant in Harlem called Raos.
You see the sauce in a lot of stores.
Yeah, I've seen that.
It's from that restaurant.
And that restaurant only has 10 tables.
It's been around since like the 20s.
You can't get a table at Raos.
Denzel Washington's in there,
the head of New York Stock Exchange is in there,
a couple of wise guys.
You cannot get a table at Raos.
I had a table, because my neighbor went to jail.
And so that definitely helped my Wall Street business,
because I was able to bring potential clients to Raos.
And that's, yeah-
And so where does the endurance impulse start to enter?
You got this like guy in your building, right?
Who's running stairs and shit?
Like, are you just gaining weight and feeling lazy
or where does it begin?
Yeah, well, go way back.
My mom introduces me to, like she's running marathon.
She introduced me to this Transcendence run in Queens,
I don't know-
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I had Sanjay Rawal on the podcast.
He made a movie about it.
Yeah, exactly.
We invested in it.
3100, oh, you did?
Yeah, we gave money to that movie
simply because of that connection to my mom.
So anyway, she introduces me to that race.
If you're listening, it's 3,100-
So was she a devotee of the guy?
That was one of her guru.
Sai Baba was another guru.
And so for those listening,
there's a race in Queens, New York called
the Transcendence run.
It's one mile loop, 3,100 times.
It takes 50 to 60 days to complete it,
and about eight people every year attempt it.
Right, right.
So anyway, she introduced me to that,
probably Ironman, I'm seeing on TV, marathons-
But you weren't an athlete in high school.
Not an athlete.
I BMX'd, that is not considered an athlete by any means,
but I was a crazy person on a BMX bike.
Like I would bike tens of miles on this bike,
and it's hard to do that with one gear, a little bike.
So that was the only skill I had,
if you could even call that a skill.
So fast forward,
when I was running the business, I'm mixing cement,
I'm laying brick, we are working physically every day.
So I've got that kind of endurance and it feels good.
Now I'm on Wall Street and I'm sitting at a desk
and we're doing two or three dinners a night
and I'm getting heavy, and I'm feeling terrible.
And I still don't want any part of yoga
or any of that crunchy stuff my mom talked about.
But one day the elevator's broken in the building
and I gotta go up to the 30 something floor.
And so I'm taking the stairs, and I'm huffing and puffing.
And there's a guy as fit as a Rich Role sitting here, right?
Not nearly as fit as you, my friend.
Rich is ripped and he's carrying two dumbbells
and he's going up the stairs.
And his name is Mike, if I remember correctly
and we're talking in the stairwell.
And I'm intrigued.
This guy like he's literally a cover
of Men's Health type guy, right?
And he's got his shirt off and we got time to talk
because we're going up all these stairs,
and he's carrying the dumbbells.
And I'm more out of breath than he is.
And he says, "Meet me in the stairs every day,
we'll start training."
And so that was the beginning.
I started training in the stairs.
He introduced me to an Adventure race.
I'd never heard of an Adventure race,
which was a three-hour race where we kayaked,
we biked, kayaked, biked and ran.
Loved it, felt like I was mixing cement again
and laying bricks and doing construction work.
And I was just like, went nuts.
Right.
Went nuts, like, where's the next one?
Where's the harder one?
Give me the hardest race in the world.
And I just chased races for...
And it was my way of eliminating some of the stress
I had on the trading desk, you know that, insanity.
And so I don't know, from like '98, '97,
'98 to like 2005, I just went nuts.
I mean you were on this ridiculous tear
where you were flying somewhere every weekend
to do something bananas.
There couldn't have been that much training during the week
in between with the work schedule that you're holding down.
So the training and the racing become one thing.
But I mean in that period of time,
I don't know if there's anybody else on the planet
who participated in more insane races than you did.
No, I went absolutely nuts,
and I call it the Spartan paradox.
And maybe you've found this as well.
That the training, you got to embrace the training, right?
It's the journey that matters.
But like training sucks,
like the actual race is kind of cool, right.
And I found that as long as I had a date on the calendar,
I always had, I never fell out of shape.
Kind of like, you know,
a boxer gets a date on the calendar.
He knows he's gotta fight-
You're just accountable, the clock's ticking.
Selfishly, I was like, if I just keep racing,
I'll just always be in shape.
I never have to train.
But you took it to such an insane level.
I mean, there's that one,
there was like a one like four-day, five-day period
you did the Vermont 100, 100-mile run.
Then you get on a plane and you fly to Vegas
and drive to Badwater, and you do Badwater,
Badwater's a race we talk about all the time on the podcast.
Then you go to a wedding, and then you go to Lake Placid
and do the Ironman, in what, like four days?
You did your research, yeah.
Five days or something like that?
The hardest part of that whole week was the wedding.
My feet did not fit in the shoes.
How do you go from running the Vermont 100
to running Badwater, I mean the hardest,
I mean, I paced Dean Karnazes at that race
and it just, it almost killed me
just trying to support that guy.
Yeah, It was hot.
It was 137 degrees the day we did it, it was hot.
My shoes melted, my shirt melted. I don't know.
You know, there's something amazing about the human body.
The body gets more efficient.
You would think like, everybody talks to me about,
well, you gotta recover or whatever.
And I don't know, if this was the 1700s, 1800s,
you and I would not like, we wouldn't stop on a mountain
with our horse and carriage and say it's recovery day today.
You just keep going.
And the human body just gets stronger or it dies.
And so I just found for me, just get stronger.
Like my fastest time, that 100-mile run in Vermont,
fly to Vegas, go to Badwater,
my fastest time in that 235 miles
was the last 13 miles up to Mount Whitney.
I was flying.
That climb is brutal.
I ran that whole thing, like a lunatic.
I probably passed eight people.
And just because your body gets more efficient.
I'm no special athlete, all I did was BMX as a kid.
I didn't, what the hell am I? You know.
The best part is how you finished the marathon
in Lake Placid though.
Yeah, yeah, well, what happened was,
I'm feeling great in the swim.
We get there, I sit in an ice tub-
(chuckles) Were you feeling great?
I'm feeling great in the swim, right?
Cold water. And I'm crushing it.
I get on the bike, I'm feeling pretty damn good on the bike.
And I'm like, you know what, this is gonna be great.
And within three or four miles on the run,
I was dead, I was smoked.
And I asked a couple of kids.
I said, hey, on the side, do you have any aspirin, advil?
They said, "No, but we've got beer."
And I don't drink, give me a beer.
And I drank one beer, two beers.
So I basically got drunk, I was eating hamburgers.
I couldn't consume enough during that marathon.
Yeah, but you got that done, man.
That is so impressive.
And then you've gone on, you did Furnace Creek.
You did this crazy like 350-mile thing in Quebec
in the wintertime.
I biked from Vermont to the Furnace Creek start line.
Get out.
Yeah.
That was a 14-day bike ride.
Oh my God, that was your training.
That was my training for that. Yeah.
Yeah. I went nuts. I went nuts.
Whatever-
There was a year where you did 50 ultras and 14 Ironmans,
that's gotta be a record.
I was in a, what happened,
the reason that happened is I was in a bad car accident
and I was thrown out the window at 85 miles an hour.
My leg was ripped out of my hip.
So I'm laying in bed, and the doctor was saying,
you're not gonna be able to walk again.
And like, crutches, wheelchair.
And I just kept going to different doctors
until I got a doctor that said, you'd be fine.
And Lisa Smith, I don't know if you know her.
She had gotten me into some of this stuff.
So she called to say, how are you?
I heard you got in a car accident.
I said, look, it doesn't look like I'll be doing
these Adventure races anymore or whatever.
She said, why don't we do Ironmans?
And maybe I had done one Ironman at that point, maybe two.
And she said, we'll just do every Ironman there is.
I said all right, let's do it, fuck it.
'Cause I was just out of the hospital.
My leg had been ripped out of my hip.
And a lot of times when you're hurt though,
you see those athletes come back stronger, right?
So it just gave me something to look forward to.
And I just, I went nuts that year.
It ended, that year ended because my wife
was eight and a half months pregnant with our first child.
I was at an Ironman.
I had just like barely came in, walking on the marathon.
I was just exhausted, as you can imagine
from doing all those things.
And she said, "Are we gonna have a family?
Or are you just gonna keep doing races?"
(Rich laughs)
Yeah, I mean, at some point, you know, it's like,
what are you running from, you know?
A lot of this is so nourishing
because it's connecting you with yourself
and your potential, and there's so much to be learned about,
you know, what we're capable of, right?
But you can also hide behind it.
Like you can run from your life by just being
in too many events all the time.
I had never been married before, so I didn't,
you know, and I was learning, navigating that.
But for me, although you might have better insight
and to me listening to me,
for me, it was more about like,
I was so stressed out in business
that whenever I got to a place where I was like,
just wanting water, food, and shelter, it was so nice.
And I just liked getting there,
just like as long as I fall asleep
in my soup at dinner, I'm happy.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, of course. Like that's what it's all about.
I mean, what do you think?
Like, what is that experience for somebody
who's never been in that position before teach you?
I guess for me, I needed to meet myself, right?
I needed to find out who I am. Am I tough enough?
I liken it to, if I had a Ferrari in the garage,
and I just looked at it and I polished it and you know,
showed photos of it, versus I took it out on the track
and I raced it up against the, you know,
however you race a race car,
you get to see how it handles.
And so I was just, I guess learning to see
how do I handle, how do I do?
And you get humble.
I don't know about you, but I gained integrity
during all those crazy adventures because,
I liken that to like a structural engineer
that checks the integrity of the parts and pieces
before he puts the building together.
Like I was testing the integrity of my parts and pieces.
And I think when you've suffered like that,
like you've suffered, like I've suffered,
it knocks the edges off.
And it's like, you know, when I meet a really tough wrestler
or a Navy seal or Delta force operator,
and they've got a somewhat soft handshake,
they're that way for that reason.
They've been through some tough shit.
They don't need to squeeze you, does that make sense?
Yeah, I get that.
I mean, I think when I think of you,
to like extend the car analogy,
like your RPMs are running so hot all the time,
because when you get back from that race,
you're in Wall Street.
So you're burning it in a different way.
So there's no like recuperation,
like it's amazing you didn't just completely flame out.
Yeah, I had zero recovery, but the other thing-
(Rich laughs)
The other thing is, I mean, I remember flying to like,
you'd be able to look this up if my memory is off,
but I remember flying once to like South Africa
to knock out an Ironman,
literally land on a Friday afternoon,
put my bike together, wake up in the morning,
do the Ironman.
At the finish line, take my bike apart,
put it in a box and leave.
And then get back to New York, work however many days I had
in New York, three days,
and then fly back to like Western Australia.
(laughing)
It's like crazy.
What are people in the office thinking?
Well, it cost me. It costs me a lot, right?
Because then the boss, if the boss-
You can't be fully present.
I wasn't present.
But that's the negative.
The negative was I was showing my people
that I wasn't really interested, right?
So that was bad for business.
But what was good for business was that became my brand.
Everybody else's brand on Wall Street
was like drinking and partying.
My brand, which didn't exist, you know, at this time
in the early 2000s, late 90s,
I'm the adventure guy that takes his customers to do yoga
and on run, nobody was doing that.
Yeah, we'd climb stairs for fun. We don't go drinking.
Yeah, yeah.
What's so unique about you, and I'm sure looking back,
you know, hindsight's 20-20,
but you're this weird amalgam of street hustler
with this kind of blue collar, you know, aesthetic,
and also like the Wall Street pedigree.
But you also have the yoga hippie thing going on
at the same time.
And all of these things fuse to create
this unique individual.
Like nobody else could be you or do what you do
without all of those elements like kind of congealing.
Yeah, and what I think about a lot is,
'cause we have four children now,
from 14 down to 8 years old,
how do you make your...
There was a great saying in ancient Sparta.
Like they need to be better than us.
Our children need to be better than us.
And so how do you make,
how do I make my kids better than me?
And they don't have the yoga crunchy mom
and the neighborhood and the wise guy next door.
They have a house where it's so organized for them
that it's almost like it's a negative, you know?
That's the problem with, you know, becoming successful.
Yeah, it's like not good for the kids in some ways.
Yeah, but you're running this crazy boot camp
up in Vermont with all these people coming through
all the time.
Yeah, so I mean the kids could carry rocks, right?
The kids could climb ropes.
But they don't have a wise guy next door that's-
Right, little street wisdom.
And so I need to figure that out.
They're learning Latin.
(laughing)
How old are they now?
I've got a 8-year-old girl, a 12-year-old girl,
a 13-year-old boy, 14-year-old boy.
Yeah, I've got two daughters, 16 and 13, two older boys.
None of them are interested in any of this stuff,
and I can't get them interested and that's fine.
I don't need them to be, but I find myself thinking,
like they'd probably be better off,
but I don't want to be the guy who's forcing them
to do something that they really
just are not wired to do.
Well, so I forced it and I continue to force it
every single day, and my theory,
and we will find out if I completely fuck this up,
but my theory is they gain,
they hate it, they hate it, they hate it.
And then all of a sudden they score a goal at a soccer game
and they see they're more fit than their peer.
And then they hear from, "Hey, you're in pretty good shape,"
the coach say, right?
And then maybe it starts to stick-
It clicks.
And I think I'm seeing that happen,
but I might be seeing what I want to see.
But I force it, I force it every day
and I've been forcing it since my oldest was four years old.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, let's take it to you.
So basically, at some point,
you rip the parachute ripcord and you're out of New York
and you decide to move to Vermont
and it's gonna be retirement.
Yeah, so I've got a picture of a red barn
on the trading desk.
Probably because in Ithaca, when I was a kid,
I saw some red barn in a field.
I mean, Ithaca is pretty idealic, it's pretty nice.
And that's what I'm visualizing the country to be.
And I meet my wife and I'm like,
I want to find a place like that.
I don't want to be around the craziness I grew up in.
I want to get away from all these crazy people
on Wall Street, and we're gonna find a farm.
And so we find this farm in Vermont,
Vermont was not in our plan.
And the mistake I made was I associated,
and this is like a JV mistake.
I associated country like Ithaca was country with like,
but there's academics in Ithaca, right?
There's a university there, you run into professors,
like it's a little more developed.
That like anywhere in the country would be like that,
but it's not.
And so we found a farm in Pittsfield, Vermont,
a tiny little town, 400 residents,
eight miles from Killington, Vermont,
the East coast, largest ski resort.
And you know, there's not a university there.
So there's a lot of negatives, there are some positives,
so not a big crap,
but it's very hard to make a living there.
And so we bought this farm, my wife was willing to move up.
We got cows and chickens and goats,
and I started putting on races.
I put trails on the side of the mountain.
I mean we did unbelievable stuff,
but it's hard to convince people,
even though it's only a gas tank away from New York,
it's hard to convince people to come up to Vermont.
But it ultimately led to me putting on a race
we call the Death Race.
Right, right.
So let's talk about this 'cause this is crazy
and still exists, right.
Still exists, and what happened was,
I was in Lake Placid Ironman one year.
I don't know when it was, it was pouring rain
like you read about,
I mean, crazy rain.
And for whatever reason,
I think I had just gotten done with the Eco challenge
in Fiji where it rained like nonstop.
I was at some race where it rained nonstop
for 10 days, nonstop.
And this is not gonna make sense,
I'm gonna sound like bullshitting.
But like I did that Ironman.
It rained, I didn't even feel,
I did not even notice it was raining.
I had just left, you know, 12 days straight
or whatever it was of rain.
And I saw a bunch of top athletes,
men and women quit that race in the middle of it.
Is that like 2008, or 2009?
I remember there was one year where it rained like crazy.
It was craziness. It had to be before that.
'Cause Death Rate started before that.
So I said, this is ridiculous.
The name of the race is Ironman,
it doesn't say like Ironman, except if it's raining.
Right. Right.
And I grew up with a mom who meditated straight
for 30 days, like this is ridiculous you'd quit
because of the rain.
So I'm looking for ways to bring people
to Pittsfield, Vermont anyway, to our new farm.
And I'm like, you know what?
We're gonna have this race called the death race
and it's gonna emulate life, and it's gonna,
there's gonna be no rules.
And it'd be like, if you get out of the swim in this race
and you get to your bike and the bike seat is missing,
so what, you gotta do it without a bike seat.
(Rich laughs)
That's gonna be what this race is, right?
'Cause that's what a CEO would do.
That's what a startup would do.
But the mindfuck goes way further with this one.
The mindfuck goes way farther.
So first year, Doug Lewis,
Olympics downhill skier shows up.
The Ashley brothers, two guys from Vermont,
I don't know any of these guys.
Two guys from Vermont who eat barbed wire for breakfast,
grew up on a bad-ass farm,
where their dad made 'em chop wood for heat,
their whole life, just tough guys.
A teacher, a female teacher and a kid I convinced
from Wall Street to show up.
It's about eight people, just like the Transcendence Run.
And they don't know when it's gonna start,
they don't know what it includes,
but it's like handsawing through a log, right?
12 chunks.
So they're there for like three hours,
handsawing through this log, splitting that wood,
crawling through a culvert.
A culvert is a hole under the ground,
this was 120 feet long that water rushes through,
that they could barely fit in,
putting together a wheelbarrow
with Japanese directions and no tools.
But the thing is, you don't tell them when it starts,
how long it's gonna go for, when it's gonna end,
or even what they're gonna be doing.
They had no idea.
No idea what they were getting into.
And, the two rugged Vermonters
and the Olympic downhill skier are battling for first.
And the teacher is, everybody else quit.
The female teacher who's in dead last by like five hours,
and we're trying to get her to quit because I can't manage
the front of the pack,
15 miles away from this woman in the back.
And she says, you'd have to kill me.
Like she literally just would not quit.
So ultimately the skier wins and the brothers come in second
and then the female comes in third after the two brothers.
And it just, the race just became this thing.
The New York Times picked up a story and they came
and filmed it.
And the world got excited,
and then all of a sudden 300 competitors every year
would descend upon Pittsville, Vermont.
And the race got tougher, and longer and crazier
with every year.
So every year you're throwing something
new at them, right?
Like it's never the same?
Didn't you have like a bus where you would stand there
and say, you can get on the bus and quit for like-
Oh, you have no idea-
(laughing) Just toying with them.
What happened was the two brothers
who I've since become great friends with,
the two brothers from that first race,
they had done lots of big races throughout their life.
These are tough guys,
crazy races in the Tundra.
Like they would have done really well in the 1700s.
And they took on the persona of the death race
after doing it that first year.
They started to make little skull necklaces,
they got tattoos, like they were just into this.
And I started to see some of the videos they were creating.
And they were training specifically
for what we had just done that first year.
And I said, they're not gonna do the same stuff
the next year, I'm gonna change everything.
And it broke 'em, it drove them crazy
because they had just trained for eight or nine months,
whatever it was, to do exactly what they...
They could put a wheelbarrow together now-
You're trying to figure out what their weaknesses are
so you can throw something at them
that's just gonna derail their whole plan.
Exactly, and so every year it became,
what are they expecting?
What are the competitors expecting
versus what are we going to throw at 'em?
(laughs) It's diabolical.
It was diabolical.
And so, you know, they would roll into town,
let's say on a Thursday night,
getting ready for a Friday afternoon start
and they'd check into the general store
and they'd have khakis on and shoes,
and they'd be with their family, and I'd say,
"Race starts right now."
They haven't even signed the waiver yet.
We're going right now, grab and ax and we're going.
And so it just became this mystical thing
that still goes on today.
Right, and there was a TV deal on the table
at one point, right, that didn't end up panning out.
Yeah, we had many, many TV deals.
We've had so many TV people come up
from The Discovery Channels, the NBCs and invariably,
everybody gets really nervous with that word,
you know, Death Race.
And it is, it's a crazy race.
People have come really close to dying.
And so it-
How Ironclad is that waiver?
In the waiver, it says, we will bury you on the property.
We might not even tell anyone.
You know, it doesn't get like a lot of media though.
You know, you don't hear that much about it.
It did, it did get a ton of media
in like 2007, 2008, but then from there,
Spartan was born and Spartan took over
and then Tough Mudder and Spartan took over.
Become a thing.
I mean Spartan is really born out of this idea.
How do we take what's great about the Death Race
and make it accessible for the average weekend warrior
and then scale it up-
And formalize it, and standardize it.
Like you're not gonna find wood chopping.
It was more military based, like standardized for Spartan.
But Death Race is my baby, and I love torturing people.
How many people show up these days,
Still about 300 people.
And how many people finish?
Depends on the year, what kind of mood I'm in?
(laughs) I like how it's up to you.
It's really up to me,
because we could go till Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
and we could say, all right,
we only want three people finishing.
So imagine you're four days into this,
just hypothetically, Rich Roll is four days in.
You can't see straight,
and there's still 12 competitors.
And I say to all 12 of you, I say,
"Guys, I'm here. We'll go as long as you want.
But until we're down to three, it doesn't end."
And people start dropping right there.
It's like Hunger Games.
Like you're overlooking the whole thing going,
how can I fuck with these people and improvising-
It's so easy to break people.
And what have you learned about the people
that break last?
Does it go back to that grit and the mental fortitude
that is more important than their physical conditioning?
No doubt about it,
you could tell right away,
the big muscular guys, they're out first.
They're out first and it's a CEO,
it's a mom that just waits everybody out.
You must get Navy SEALs and guys like that coming in.
I lost a Green Beret out there once.
Literally lost him, we had search dogs, the whole thing.
We found them in the attic of one of my barns sleeping.
We had shut the whole race down,
looking for a Green Beret.
We've had them all, we've had every form of military,
MMA, all of them have come out to try to test themselves.
But you know, a lot of them quit
in the first three, four hours.
Wow.
Just like, this is insane.
This guy's nuts.
Right.
So Spartan race begins.
I mean, you're up in Vermont kind of trying
to be semi-retired and instead you build this empire.
Yeah, so I'm done, we're having children
and this was gonna be like my time to recover.
We talked about recovery.
And Death Race leads to this idea of Spartan race
and 700 people show up to that first event in Vermont.
And I happened to have Discovery Channel.
There's a guy from Discovery Channel at that first event.
And he's seeing people across this,
it's just a three-mile race
and they're crossing the finish line.
He's like, "Oh my God, are you seeing
there's transformations that take place?"
And I'm not really paying attention to that
because I've got logistical problems,
any race organized, you're dealing
with other stuff, toilet paper.
And he's like, this is unbelievable what's happening here.
And that gives me the impetus,
all right, we're gonna put on a second race
and a third race and a fourth race.
And then 1,500 people showed up and then 3000
and then Tough Mudder came onto the scene.
And so then I'm a pretty competitive guy,
then everybody's like-
That's like not getting into Cornell.
I gotta bury these guys and be the best.
I'm gonna win this thing.
And so if they were in the US and Australia,
we're going to Slovakia, we're gonna be...
I'm gonna go anywhere they're not,
and we're gonna, we're just gonna win this war.
And really that battle between Tough Mudder and Spartan
I think drove both of us, the founders,
me and the founders of Mudder to really build an industry,
build a sport out of this thing.
Yeah, the difference from my perspective
is that with Spartan, there's this elite aspect to it
where you're able to tap
into a different caliber of athlete.
And that allows the weekend warriors to compete alongside
like these people that are like, you know,
who become the Emilia Boons and the like,
who get really celebrated for this stuff.
Yeah, I mean, that was the difference.
The difference was they, Tough Mudder went out
and branded it, it's not a race, right?
This is an experience.
And we're actually gonna laugh in the face
of people wanting a medal at the finish line.
We're gonna give them an orange headband.
Like that was their shtick.
And our thing was, if I'm gonna do this,
I wanna make it a real sport.
And honestly, it was a business mistake on my part
because it was harder to build what I was building,
They were much more inclusive, like right?
A bunch of guys high fiving,
they could skip obstacles and they could just earn
a headband and drink a bunch of beer.
I was asking people to like train and work hard.
And if you didn't do an obstacle, you had to do 30 burpees.
Who the hell wants to do that?
So I was losing the battle for a long time,
but because I'm such, I'm just don't quit,
we ultimately won.
Yeah, we ultimately won.
That is your superpower.
Just you're the Eveready battery
that's just never gonna run out of energy.
My team, my Spartan team says,
I'm very much like a battery on your phone
that's like just out of juice, but doesn't die somehow.
(laughing) Like you're always at 6%.
Yeah, exactly, and it just doesn't die.
Aha, that's funny.
The other thing that's cool about what you do is,
I mean it would be normal for somebody like you
who's so focused on building Spartan
and all the things that you're involved in
to just be focused on that.
But you really opened up your farm
and you have all these people that come through.
It's like this open door policy,
like, hey, you want to come here?
We got a bunk house, stay as long as you like,
but you're gonna have to do what I tell you to.
So you're still doing this
kind of one-on-one coaching and mentoring.
And there's been some pretty extraordinary success stories
that have come out of that.
Yeah, I do it.
You know, my wife hates it, right,
because I think I invited three million people
to the farm once, but people don't really,
you know, it's a little Tom Sawyer-ish, right?
It's a little karate kid, right?
What was his name? Mr. Miyagi, right?
Like you come here,
you can paint the fence and do this and that.
And people don't really want to do it.
They might not be happy with their life,
they want to lose weight, whatever it is,
they're trying to clean up things
and they think they want to come.
But in most cases when they get there, they tap out.
There's a few unbelievable success stories.
The paples guy, right?
The apples guy was an amazing success story.
A truck driver, 300 pounds.
He probably should have been 160 pounds.
I got him down to 200 pounds in 30 days.
He shows up with a little wheelie suitcase.
He's like, all right, you know,
where am I staying at or whatever.
I'm like, up there.
"Up where?"
Top of the mountain.
In the rafter.
(laughs)
He takes the wheelie suitcase,
he's literally climbing up the mountain with this,
like four or five hours.
Gets up there, I got him in a stone cabin.
He's like, you know, where's the shower or the kitchen?
There are none.
And a big bushel of apples, all you're getting is apples.
We're hiking every day, lost 100 pounds in 30 days,
obviously extreme, obviously easy to bounce back from that.
But like, that's the deal like,
they can't do it on their own.
And so I provide that ability to do it-
Structured environment, and strip everything else away.
Take the phone away, take the food away.
And yeah, if they give me their keys
and they give me their wallet,
we can get them to succeed at anything
they want to succeed at.
But as soon as they have a plan B or a way to escape,
I can't help 'em.
Right, so the recidivism rate, you can't control.
I can't control.
I mean I had two guys show up two months ago,
big, jacked guys during COVID.
I had a bunch of kids come, family friends.
They sent all the kids, I put them through hell.
And two guys wanted to come.
I said, you can come while the kids are here.
I'm putting on a 14-day, yeah, no problem.
And they spoke with like military lingo.
They were not military guys.
And they were gonna crush it. Three hours.
Kids stayed 14 days. These guys made it three hours.
Wow. So what's the differentiator there?
They could leave. They could leave.
I mean, when you can leave, you take that option.
And I learned that, you know, in this town,
we didn't talk about, I rebuilt a general store
that had been around from the 1800s.
I rebuilt a farm that have been around from the 1800s.
And I envisioned finding some entrepreneurs,
like I was back in the neighborhood
to come run these things.
It'd be cool to come run a general store, right?
And you're not gonna have to get a mortgage and all that.
It's all paid for. It's all ready for you.
Turnkey, just walk in.
And this farm has a tractor and cows,
all you gotta do is work.
You just gotta do the work.
You're going to crush it because you don't have the strains
that any other entrepreneur has, where you got to borrow,
and you got to figure out ways to make this work.
I even have a place for you to live.
They all quit, and they quit because-
They're not invested personally.
They're not invested.
Like when you write a check and you sell your kids
and do whatever you have to do to make it,
you have no choice.
And so that's the big difference.
You know, with the Death Race, they were all quitting.
And then one year I said, here's what we're going to do.
If you want to do the Death Race,
you have to get an article written in a local newspaper
that says you are doing this race and you're gonna finish.
And all of a sudden finishing rates went up, it's that easy.
Right?
That's amazing.
All these people that have come through the farm,
all the people that you've seen compete
in these Spartan races, all the athletes that you've,
you know, run shoulder to shoulder with
over the course of these races,
what are the lessons that you take away
from all of these experiences that can inform
the person who's at the starting gate
of a journey like this?
Well, so I'm a big subscriber in this idea
of fire, ready, aim, right?
Just get started. Just take that first step.
Just go outside. You know this,
I think we all get stuck sitting around.
Our brains are wired to avoid discomfort.
And so I find myself, I know every day,
I gotta take my cold shower
and I find myself looking at my phone and I'm like,
why the fuck am I looking at my...
Oh, I'm looking at my phone
because I don't want to get in the cold shower.
Subconsciously you know, my brain is telling me
to avoid that pain I'm about to go deal with.
So just take that first step,
and that first step leads to another step
and before you know it, you get it done.
And that might be signing up for something,
that might be telling a friend,
you're gonna go do something,
or maybe just having a friend ring your bell in the morning
or having your shoes next to your bed.
Whatever that is, just take that first step.
Number two, and I'm doing this a long time.
So I think you have to have a frame of reference
that you could fall back on when the going gets tough.
So what do I mean by that?
Like, I always go to a place when the, and I say, well,
it could be worse.
Like I could be in Siberia, I could be missing an arm.
God forbid, one of my kids could be like,
I go through this place where it's like,
it's not so bad, when I refer to some other thing
that could be my reality.
And I think when you do that,
you have gratitude for where you are versus resentment.
And that's important to understand it, right?
There's a lot of people that resent,
like I should have what he has or she has, or this or that.
I never think that, I think like,
thank God I have what I have,
because I don't have what they have, which is worse.
You know what I mean?
And is it the result of all these experiences
that you've like, you know,
basically brought upon yourself that allows you
to tap into gratitude in that way?
No doubt about it.
If I didn't feel the pain and suffering,
I wouldn't know how bad,
like as bad as it's been for me or you
when we've done these races,
which are really just manufactured adversity.
We're still not like in the Lewis and Clark expedition.
You know what I mean?
It's not Donner pass.
It's not that bad, right?
But you wouldn't know that if you grew up on Park Avenue,
you were pampered your whole life.
So that's probably why the MMA fighter and the Navy SEAL,
that's probably why their handshake is a little softer,
and they're more humble 'cause they've seen hell.
But with success now you're flying around,
you're managing this huge business,
you're trying to direct all of these races.
I know for myself, you know, I'm sitting at a table
having conversations with people more than I am
getting out after it.
Like, as a result of the things that we're interested in,
we create a certain large S in our lives
that actually makes it more difficult.
Like I found myself having to exercise,
you know, stronger boundaries
and challenge myself more to get out of this comfort zone
that I've created for myself.
Do you feel, I mean-
No doubt it.
And now you got kids and you can't go
do 14 Ironmans in a year, and all of that.
Like, do you miss it?
And how do you, you know, stay connected with that impulse
to be in discomfort?
I feel like it would be selfish of me,
certainly for my family if I did my,
you know, go back to the old days and Saturdays
were my 12-hour day.
If I did that on a Saturday and I stayed away from my kids,
that would be selfish.
And then the other thing is, I'm so fortunate.
I get these emails all day, every day,
that you wouldn't even believe.
I'm back with my husband, I'm back with my wife,
I lost 200 pounds, I left my job and started a business
because of Spartan.
You can't even believe the emails I get all day, every day.
And so, yes, it'd be cool to go hike a mountain
or do something but like,
and I get asked by all my old friends, right?
We're going to climb this, or we're going to do that,
and you want, no, I can't.
I got a family, and I got a business
and we're doing great work here.
So I wake up early, I wake up super early.
I get my workout, and I sweat every single day,
I take the cold showers,
and I run-
And you told Rogan that you bring,
you have like a 44-pound kettlebell that you travel with.
Did you bring it here? Is it here?
I did not bring my kettlebell
because the last three flights,
I don't know if it's because of COVID,
maybe there's less people working at the airlines
they're losing it.
So I ended up landing somewhere where the some, like you,
are expecting to see it
and I gotta run and go buy one locally quickly to...
So I just, I didn't bring it.
And that stems from,
that kettlebell stems from one of the people
that came to the farm, Chris Davis.
Was 696 pounds, and he wanted to get down in the 200s.
And I told him, as you lose weight, I'll carry weight.
And so he got down the first 100 pounds,
I was carrying 100 pounds on a sand bag.
And it was, as you could imagine, difficult.
And it's another whole story,
but we moved to Asia as a family right after that.
And so I had this 100 pound sandbag that I was carrying
because I made that commitment to him,
and they confiscated it at the airport.
So when I landed in Japan or Singapore,
I said to my wife, can you order on Amazon?
Can you get a kettlebell?
I don't need 100 pounds.
I'll carry, just to keep it going,
I'll carry like a 20-pounder.
It came 20 kilograms, which was, you know,
44 pounds or whatever.
So that became my thing.
And for the last four or five years,
I've pretty much carried it everywhere outside of COVID.
Yeah, that's gotta be a trip though
when it comes through on the baggage claim
or trying to carry that thing on an airplane.
Yeah, it almost took out one of those security officers
once, you know, coming down the ramp.
In India, they stuck it in somebody else's suitcase
once I checked it in.
I had to open somebody else's suitcase to get it out.
In the middle East, they use a term to mean it's up to God,
whether or not it will be there when I land.
So it's been a trip carrying this thing around
and it's become a shtick.
Yeah, so how many people do Spartan pre-COVID,
how many people would you-
Pre-COVID, so I don't know if you know this.
Right before COVID we purchased Tough Mudder,
we bought Tough Mudder.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
So pre-COVID, if you look at Spartan and Tough Mudder,
we're probably 1.6, 1.7 million people around the world.
During COVID we're like 20,000.
Right, yeah, yeah.
Fucking disaster.
But it's a big number, 45 countries, 325 events,
two companies combined, and yeah.
Right, and you have this mission statement though,
that you're gonna impact 100 million people.
Our goal is to change a 100 million lives,
gets us a free pass to heaven.
And I'm excited about that.
(Rich laughs)
So how do we scale this thing up?
I mean, you've got your books, you've got the podcast,
you've got the documentary, you've got the races.
I don't know what else you can do to impact people at scale,
other than what you're already doing.
Like at the same time, when you canvas what's going on
in America and across the developed world,
we're dealing with a health crisis of untold proportion.
You know, obesity rates are through the roof.
Childhood obesity rates are through the roof,
diabetes, heart disease, all of these lifestyle illnesses
that are just felling millions of people unnecessarily.
There's still so many people that are suffering
and challenged to find their way, you know,
to a healthier way of being.
Yeah, no, I'm in the wrong business for sure.
All the data-
I don't think you're in the wrong business.
Well, I'm in the right business
'cause it's something you and I are passionate about, right?
Getting people off the couch and doing these things.
I'm in the wrong business in that the data
is going in the wrong direction.
More and more people are eating unhealthy,
more and more people are sitting and watching Netflix,
especially post-COVID.
It's gonna be even harder to get people pried off the couch.
So I would say if we could snap our fingers,
sitting here and do anything,
we would have to get to the White House and convince them
or the Pentagon and convince them that they have
to work with us to mandate this kind of physical activity.
Like it's the only way it's gonna work
if you want to get to 100 million people.
Because most look at me and I'm sure they look at you
and say like, why would I do that?
Why would I do that?
Netflix, I can lay naked in bed
like Gary V talks about, right?
And do nothing.
So it's a tough, it's a very tough sell
outside of the, let's call you and I, the hunter gatherers.
Outside of the remaining hunter gatherer genes
that still exist, it's a tough sell.
Yeah, remember when we were kids
and there was the presidential physical fitness thing.
Does that even exist anymore or did just that go
by the way of the dodo?
I don't think so.
And it wasn't that big of a deal,
but at least it was something.
You need that.
And now we have like lip service
to like corporate wellness programs, which, you know,
I question how effective they are.
It's like getting people excited about going out
and walking around or standing up
every 10 minutes or something like that.
Like how do you have a soft enough touch
that you can get that person
who's never experienced anything hard
to at least get interested in it,
but not come at them so hard like with your, you know,
kind of super hardcore sensibility that they're intimidated
and scared and never do anything?
It's tough when you, that's why you need programs,
that it becomes part of, it's normal, right?
When my mom got into all this stuff, it wasn't normal.
So it didn't get accepted.
And so we just need to make it normal.
I've lived on the farm, we moved to Asia,
we moved to Japan, Singapore-
When did you do that?
And why did you do that?
We did that because the business was growing fast.
I needed to beat Tough Mudder.
They weren't in Asia yet.
And the kids were still young enough to move.
So I said to my wife, why don't we move?
We'll go Asia light,
we'll live in Singapore first, easy to do.
We'll land there, we'll start putting on Spartan.
And then we'll expand from Singapore.
And what an amazing experience as a family.
But the reason I bring it up is
because when I lived in those places,
the neighbors right around us started sending their kids
to me early in the morning to work out with my kids.
So I can do it if I have close proximity to people.
I could rope them in, give them the olive branch,
lie to them a little bit, you know,
and get them to do more than
they would willingly do otherwise.
But you know, when they're five degrees separated,
as you know, it's hard to get them to do stuff.
Look at the size of people, look at the data.
It's not going, you know,
they'd prefer Twinkies over this.
Right, so a cabinet position
in the White House for physical fitness.
You can't say, whether you like Trump or Biden,
it doesn't really matter.
You can't have a tagline that say
let's make America great again
without making America fit again,
you-
100%.
It's logical.
Anybody listening to this, we have to make America fit.
And it has to be a policy-driven thing.
My friend ran New York city schools food program,
$1.1 billion budget.
He's just like you and I, he did it because he wanted.
He left Goldman Sachs.
He did it because he really wanted to make an impact.
He left, he says I got the potato lobby,
I gotta have the French fries.
I got the soda lobby, I got to have the soda.
And he goes, I finally I convinced I was able
to get wheat bread on the hamburgers, right?
He goes, so I put wheat bread on the hamburgers,
the bun, none of the kids will eat it.
So then I had to put a wheat bottom with a white top
to hide the wheat.
So he just couldn't take it anymore.
Well, you have to change the entire political system
to get, you know, the lobbying efforts out of there
that keep you know, everything entrenched
with the shitty food,
because there's too much money involved right now.
So it's impossible for a guy like that to come in
and make any changes.
I mean look at how Michelle Obama just got shellacked
for just saying maybe we should eat a little bit healthier.
I know, and so it's gotta...
Somehow you gotta have a politician
or a group of politicians that get it.
You and I have to run for office.
I mean that's the only way this is going to work.
How's your mom rubbing off on you
in terms of like the yoga and the spirituality and the diet?
Like what's that look like for you these days?
I went crazy with the yoga,
but it had to be hot yoga, as you could imagine,
I had to be sweating.
I couldn't be like sitting still and like chanting.
So I went nuts with the hot yoga.
I probably did a thousand classes or something. Love it.
Haven't done enough of it lately.
And on the spirituality front,
I don't know, my mom used to say, look,
no matter what religion, you just gotta be a good person.
So my thing is just be a good person.
She around still?
Gone, didn't make it.
She died very young.
Her mom had cancer.
As I said, she got cancer.
Her sister got cancer. Her cousin got cancer.
We lived in that neighborhood I described,
within a 15 mile radius,
there was a big garbage dump
and massive incidents of cancer around that garbage dump.
Oh, wow. Wow.
So diet, she preached more plant-based.
She introduced me to a guy named Fred Bisci.
I don't know if that name-
Oh yeah, yeah, he's John Joseph's boy.
My buddy, John Joseph, New York city.
Hardcore Ironman, vegan, punk rocker dude.
But he's all about Bisci, talks about Bisci all the time.
Guy's like, is he still alive?
Yeah, he's still alive.
He was at my wedding-
He's what? 92, 94, something like that?
93, probably.
He's a good friend. He was texting me today.
And so I subscribed more to plant-based,
but that doesn't mean a little bit of animal protein
doesn't slip in to my diet.
It shouldn't, but it does, but I'm mostly,
I'm probably 75, 80% plant based and I should be more,
and I fight with everybody over it, including my own kids.
Right, it's interesting because Spartan, which is sort of,
you know, kind of a cousin of like the CrossFit movement,
there's a cross-pollination.
It feels like should be raw meat.
Yeah, it's very kind of intertwined
with the paleo community
that's now pivoting towards this weird carnivore diet thing
that is confusing.
I know, I know.
But that's kind of the sensibility of a lot of the people
that are participating in your races.
And it's interesting that you're coming
from a different place.
Yeah, I mean Bisci, first of all, I tested it on myself.
I did very long distance races, like crazy races.
The (indistinct) by foot, right?
And I would carry like carrots and olive oil with me
and all kinds of stuff that like doesn't,
they don't make any sense, but I performed best on that.
And so I'm just not a believer.
That said maybe based on where you come from on the planet,
maybe some people need a little more meat than others.
I don't know.
But Bisci's thing is you wanna outlive your competition.
And if you subscribe to that,
I promise you plant based is the way to go.
Yeah, Bisci was like,
he was like a weightlifter or something when he was younger?
He was a weightlifter, and he said
he was going to try different ways,
55 years in right now on raw fruits and veggies.
55 Years, raw fruits and veggies.
Yeah, what are the big obstacles
that you face for yourself now?
Like what are the things that you struggle with
dealing with and overcoming?
Well, my biggest obstacle is I got 20 years of my life
invested in this thing.
I levered up right before COVID
and bought my competitor, Tough Mudder.
And my whole life is upside down right now, financially-
So how are you maintaining your sanity?
'Cause there so much you can't control, right?
Netflix and Twinkies, man. (laughs)
What are you doing in LA?
I came out to LA, I have a thing tonight.
This is a funny story actually.
Ayn Rand, "Atlas Shrugged", you know the book,
"Atlas Shrugged" or "Fountainhead".
I get asked on podcasts like this,
like which one is your favorite books?
And I'm like "Atlas Shrugged".
So I guess there's an Ayn Rand society
that reached out to me and said,
oh, I know that your favorite book is "Atlas Shrugged,"
so can you come to this thing?
So Laird Hamilton, Gabby Reese, maybe Peter Thiel
some people will be there tonight.
And I said, I promised pre-COVID I would be at it.
So I gotta go to this thing.
That'll be an interesting crowd of people.
It's gonna be interesting.
Yeah, how does, you know, how you look at the world
and think about people and potential effect,
the kind of people that you hire for your business?
Like when you're looking to bring somebody on
into your organization,
like, what are the qualities that stand out to you?
You know, in the early days,
because I just didn't have enough funding to do
what we were trying to do, size and scale,
it would be if they had a heartbeat,
they were good enough to work for us.
'Cause I was paying like $2,000 a month
for the first 100 people to make this thing work.
Expenses were just insane.
I would say now, if we really narrowed it down
a much more professional approach,
it's you gotta be really enthusiastic person.
You gotta be like, relentless.
I don't even care if you have domain expertise or not
'cause you can learn that.
But if you're just relentless and 24/7,
and just like not gonna accept no,
and you're honest and you've got integrity,
that's good for me
Yeah, the specific skillset can be trained.
I don't care about that.
But it's more about that,
it's more about the disposition.
Yeah, I just I want...
You know that, what is it?
Pareto's principle, right?
20% of the people do 80% of the work.
I just want more of those, I just want more of those 20s.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we'll wrap this up with some thoughts
for the person that feels stuck,
who's inspired by what you just shared and is looking for,
you know, that little dose of inspiration to just start,
to get out of that cycle of analysis paralysis
that, you know, keeps you on the couch,
scrolling for the best pair of running shoes.
You gotta sign up for something.
It could be learning a new language.
What about when we can't sign up for anything right now?
Signing up for something could be as simple
as saying to your friend and then screaming it
from the rooftop, so you're committed, you're on the hook,
we are gonna walk six miles on Saturday.
I mean that could be the thing you sign up.
It's just gotta be, could be,
we're gonna learn a new language by this date, right?
It's gotta be, this is what we're gonna do
and by this date, we're gonna be held accountable.
And then I would say, you know, we have a prayer at Spartan.
Our brand has a prayer and we stole it
from a World War II French paratrooper,
who they found in the field dead.
They pulled the prayer out of his pocket.
And basically he was saying, look, God,
everybody is asking you for the good stuff, right?
They want to get back with their spouse,
they want to get home, a warm shower, a meal.
You probably don't have any of that left.
So I'll just ask you for the tough stuff.
Like the turmoil, the toil, suffering,
and just promise me, you'll keep it coming
and you gave me the strength to deal with it.
So like, if you can turn your thinking around
to more like that, like I might,
you and I might text you and say,
hey, Rich, I hope you have a day.
And that's like, a worthwhile day.
You gotta fight through today, right?
We don't want a complacent, easy day.
And so if you can change your mindset
to like embracing tough stuff and committing to it,
you just have a better life.
And what do you think is the main obstacle
that gets in people's way?
Well, I think subconsciously our legacy hardware
and software is avoiding discomfort.
Like it kept us from falling off cliffs
and freezing out in the snow and drowning.
And the sooner you recognize
that that's just like old hardware that you don't need
because you're not gonna get attacked by a lion
when you go outside or drown in the rain,
you gotta do this stuff.
Look, I have a friend who runs the largest hedgefund
in the world.
He doesn't need to do anything, okay? He's fine.
And his theory was no pain, no pain.
Instead of no pain, no gain,
no pain, why would I want any pain?
And lately he's come around to my way of thinking,
which is, and your way of thinking, which is,
you know what, look,
he came to Japan when I was living in Japan
and they had all these five-star hotels,
everything all lined up to do.
And you know what I did, I took him and his family
to the waterfall monks and it was freezing.
It was winter time, and there was ice on the mountain.
A waterfall is coming down and we got to go down to nothing,
take all our clothes off,
get down to basically nothing and get under that waterfall
and hold these metal chains while the Japanese
in their language are pulling the demons out of us.
And he said, that was the best part of the whole trip.
Yeah, he's not gonna forget that.
That was the best part of the whole trip.
It wasn't the fancy hotels, the fancy...
Like that suffering was awesome. So just do it.
Way to stick the landing.
Powerful, Joe De Sena, thank you, my friend.
It's great to see you.
You're awesome.
Yeah, that was very cool.
Appreciate it.
If you're digging on Joe, pick up his book,
"Spartan up" "Spartan Fit" "The Spartan Way".
Got the Spartan up podcast.
We didn't even talk about the Spartan X leadership stuff
that you're doing.
Leadership, we've got all kinds of stuff.
Shoot me an email at joe@spartan.com.
And if you come to the farm just don't quit.
It would suck,
I mean it would really ruin Rich's reputation
if you came to the farm based on this talk with Rich
and you were one of those ones that quit right away.
Yeah, that might be me. I might show up.
You're just gonna push me too hard
and I'm gonna be out of here, my whole ship's gonna sink.
Hopefully not.
All right. Thanks man.
Thank you.
Peace.